Bill Langworthy makes reality TV shows. He was one of the producers of The Hills . And he says that he's always been surprised, even after doing this for years, at how people end up doing things on television they would never do in real life, throwing themselves into the part so completely they even confuse themselves.
Bill Langworthy 制作真人秀节目。他曾是《The Hills》的制片人之一。他说，即便从事这项工作多年，他依然感到惊讶：人们最终竟然会在电视上做出他们在现实生活中绝不会做的事，甚至完全沉浸在角色中，以至于连他们自己都搞混了。
I mean, we literally shot scenes before a husband and wife, and midway through the scene, the wife turns to me and says, "Hold on a second, is this for the show, or are we really fighting right now?" And I couldn't answer her.
我的意思是，我们曾实打实地拍摄过一对夫妻的场景，拍到一半时，妻子转过头问我：“等一下，这是在演节目，还是我们真的在吵架？”我根本回答不上来。
So Bill never totally got why so many people would let themselves do so many embarrassing things on camera that they would never do normally.
所以 Bill 一直没能完全理解，为什么那么多人愿意在镜头前做出他们在平时绝不会做的尴尬举动。
And I would always say, gosh, if I were on one of these shows, if I was in this situation, I would just handle myself so differently.
我总是会说，天哪，如果我是这些节目中的一员，如果我处在那种情况下，我处理自己的方式肯定大不相同。
And after years of being in jobs like this and thinking all that, he went to a Dodgers game.
在从事这类工作多年并一直这么想之后，他去现场看了道奇队的比赛。
And I was there with my ex-girlfriend's best friend. And all you need to know-- it's my ex-girlfriend's best friend. This is a girl that I cannot kiss under any circumstances. There are just so many rules against that. And this guy comes around whose job it is to find people to go on the Kiss Cam, which is when they put the camera on you.
当时我和前女友最好的朋友在一起。你只需要知道这一点——那是前女友最好的朋友。这个女孩在任何情况下我都不能吻她。规矩实在太多了。这时，有个负责在大屏幕接吻（Kiss Cam）环节寻找亲吻对象的工作人员走了过来，这就是把镜头对准你的时候。
Oh, and it shows up on, like, the jumbotron for the stadium to see.
哦，而且它会出现在体育场的大屏幕上让大家看到。
Yeah, exactly. And so we were also there with two of our friends who were married. And so they signed up, that, yeah, we're going to come back later in the game with a camera on you guys. So you guys will kiss and everyone will see it on the jumbotron.
是的，没错。我们当时还和一对已婚朋友在一起。所以他们确定了，待会儿比赛间隙镜头会转向你们。这样你们就会接吻，所有人都会在大屏幕上看到。
And they'll cheer.
然后他们会欢呼。
Yeah, and sort of realized now that that guy and I have exactly the same profession, which is we try and find strangers to do embarrassing things on camera. But at the time, none of that's registering with me. And so several innings later and several beer runs later, we've managed to switch seats.
对，我当时意识到，那个人和我的职业完全一样，我们都在试图寻找陌生人来在镜头前做出尴尬的事情。但在当时，这些念头完全没在我脑子里。几个回合后，又去买了几次啤酒，我们不知怎么换了座位。
And of course, that's how they do it, is by what seat you're in. You know, 50,000 people, you don't just say, it's the tall guy with brown hair. So the Kiss Cam comes around, and instead of being pointed at the married couple, it's pointing at me and my ex-girlfriend's best friend.
当然，他们就是根据你坐的座位来定人的。你要知道，有 5 万人，你不能只说“就是那个留着棕色长发的高个子”。所以“接吻镜头”转过来时，没有对准那对已婚夫妇，而是对准了我跟我前女友的最好朋友。
Because now you're in those seats.
因为你现在坐在那些座位上。
Exactly. And so I have a producer who's looking at me. I expect something of you. The stadium is literally screaming at us. Five seconds earlier, I would have promised you, under no circumstances would I ever kiss this woman. And I leaned over and kissed her on the lips.
没错。我有一个制片人正在看着我。我对你有期望。体育场里的人简直在向我们尖叫。五秒钟前，我还会向你保证，无论如何我都绝不会吻这个女人。但我还是靠过去吻了她的嘴唇。
He knew he didn't have to kiss her. There'd be no penalty. There was no contract. No money had changed hands.
他知道他不必吻她。不会有任何惩罚。没有合同。也没有任何金钱交易。
That didn't even cross my mind. Not doing it was not an option. You couldn't have paid me $1 million to do it, but I was on camera, I had to do it.
这甚至没在我脑子里闪过。不吻不是一个选项。你就算给我 100 万美元让我做这件事我都不干，但我当时在镜头前，我必须得做。
Yeah, but that makes no sense. You of all people know that you don't have to do it.
是的，但这说不通。你可是最清楚你没必要这么做的人。
I certainly would have told you that right ahead of time. But yeah, I just got this feeling that I was letting everybody down, I was letting the producer down, that I was letting the audience down.
如果是事先问我，我肯定会那样告诉你。但当时我就是有种感觉，我觉得我让所有人失望了，我让制片人失望了，我让观众失望了。
50,000 people were looking at the jumbotron. They wanted one thing and one thing only. I realize I guess I'm just not that much different than the people that I put on TV.
5 万人正看着大屏幕。他们只想要一件东西，也只有一件东西。我意识到，我想我其实和那些被我放上电视的人没什么两样。
Well, today on our radio program, people who are driven to act very differently than who they really are, flipping their personalities, completely doing the exact opposite of what they normally do. You only go that far if there are very powerful reasons to do it.
好了，今天我们的广播节目要探讨的是：那些被驱使着做出与真实自我截然不同行为的人，他们改变了性格，完全做了与平时相反的事情。只有在有非常强大的理由时，你才会走到那一步。
In Act One, it is somebody doing this for money. In Act Two, it's somebody doing it for love. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
第一幕，有人是为了钱这么做。第二幕，有人是为了爱这么做。来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际分发。我是 Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, The Audacity of Louis Ortiz. Usually when you play a part, the expectations are pretty clear. There are lines. There's a script. There's a storyline you follow.
第一幕，Louis Ortiz 的胆量。通常当你扮演一个角色时，期望值是很明确的。有台词。有剧本。有你要遵循的故事情节。
So when you're on the Kiss Cam, you kiss. When you're Hamlet, you stress out. You know what you're on stage to do. Our first story today is about a man who found himself in a part with huge expectations and no script whatsoever. He had to make it up as he went along.
所以当你出现在“接吻镜头”里时，你就要接吻。当你是哈姆雷特时，你就要感到焦虑。你知道你在舞台上要做什么。今天我们的第一个故事是关于一个发现自己身处一个期望值巨大但完全没有剧本的角色中的男人。他必须在进行的过程中随机应变。
It comes to us from filmmaker, Ryan Murdock. A warning to listeners that this is a story that's partly about race, and a racial slur gets used.
这个故事来自电影制作人 Ryan Murdock。在此警告听众，这是一个部分涉及种族的故事，其中使用了一个种族歧视的称呼。
2008 was a hard year for Louis Ortiz. He was living in the Bronx, but he lost his job as a phone technician for Verizon over a year earlier. So he was collecting workers' comp and playing in pool tournaments for extra spending money. But then things started to change.
2008 年对 Louis Ortiz 来说是艰难的一年。他住在布朗克斯区，但在一年多前就失去了 Verizon 电话技术员的工作。所以他靠领工伤补偿金和参加台球比赛赚取额外零花钱。但后来事情开始发生变化。
I think it was, like, August '08, people were like, oh, dude, you made the front page. I'm like, what? I don't know what the hell people are talking about. So I look at the page, Daily News I believe it was, and there's this dude with big ears, just smiling. He's running against Hillary, or whatever.
我想大概是 08 年 8 月，人们说，哦，伙计，你上头条了。我说，什么？我不知道人们在说什么鬼话。所以我看了看报纸，应该是《每日新闻》，上面有个大耳朵的家伙，正在笑。他在和希拉里竞选之类的。
And I'm like, all right, I don't really get it. I think it's the big ear thing. Three weeks went by of those jokes.
我说，好吧，我真的不明白。我想是因为大耳朵的事。那种笑话持续了三周。
Louis is a Puerto Rican guy in his late 30s. He describes himself as an occasional voter. And he hadn't really been following the election.
Louis 是一名 30 多岁的波多黎各人。他称自己为偶尔投票的选民。他并没有怎么关注那场选举。
Then, at some point, Louis went to his usual bar, The Williamsbridge Tavern, to shoot some pool. Pat Tebelis was tending bar that day. Louis sat down and asked for a Corona.
后来，有一天，Louis 去他常去的酒吧 The Williamsbridge Tavern 打台球。Pat Tebelis 那天在那当酒保。Louis 坐下来点了一瓶科罗娜啤酒。
I just mentioned it to him. I said, did anybody ever tell you you look like this guy that's running for the president?
我只是对他提了一下。我说，有人告诉过你，你长得像那个竞选总统的家伙吗？
And I said, "Yeah. Who, this dude, Obama?" And he goes, "Yeah. You really look like him."
我说：“是啊。谁？这个叫奥巴马的家伙？”他回答：“对。你真的看起来很像他。”
And he says, "Yeah. yeah, yeah." He sort of blew it off.
他说：“没错。是啊，是啊。”他有点没当回事。
I'm like, "I don't see it, dude."
我说：“我不觉得像啊，哥们。”
And I said, "No, no, really. You really do." And he says, "Nah, I don't know." I said, "I'm telling you. You go home and you shave off that goatee and mustache."
我说：“不，不，真的。你真的很像。”他说：“不，我不知道。”我说：“我告诉你，你回家把那山羊胡子和八字胡刮掉。”
I'm like, uh-uh. I ain't taking this off.
我说，呃呃。我才不剃掉。
Ever since he's been in the Army, Louis had had facial hair. For more than a decade, it had been the same-- full mustache, full goatee. He never would have dreamt of taking it off. But then Pat brought up something no one else had.
自从参军以来，Louis 就一直留着胡子。十多年来，一直都是这个样子——浓密的胡须，完整的山羊胡。他做梦也没想到要把它刮掉。但后来 Pat 提到了其他人从未注意到的事情。
I told him, I said, "You could make money. If this guy does become the president, it's a tremendous opportunity for you to make money, if you want to go in that direction. You know, first black man to be the president of the United States." I said, "This is powerful."
我告诉他，我说：“你可以赚钱。如果这个人真的当上了总统，如果你想朝那个方向发展，这对你来说是一个巨大的赚钱机会。你知道，第一位黑人美国总统。”我说：“这很有影响力。”
And I'm thinking, hey, cha-ching. I need money right now. I'm unemployed for a whole year, so I start listening to the dude, listening to the dude.
我在想，嘿，有钱赚。我现在需要钱。我已经失业整整一年了，所以我开始听那个家伙的话，听那个家伙的话。
I said, "Look, I'll tell you what. You go home. If you're willing to shave your mustache and your goatee, put on a white shirt, put on a tie, look in the mirror. If you don't think you look like this guy," I said, "then just grow your mustache and your goatee back. Take the shot, go see."
我说：“听着，我跟你说。你回家。如果你愿意刮掉你的胡须和山羊胡，穿上一件白衬衫，打上领带，照照镜子。如果你不觉得你看起来像那个人，”我说，“那你就再把胡子留回来。试一下，去看看吧。”
So Louis walked a few blocks back to his one-bedroom apartment, found the clippers, found the razor, and got busy.
于是 Louis 走了几个街区回到他的一居室公寓，找出了推剪，找出了剃须刀，开始忙活起来。
Once I took it all off, I looked at myself, put the aftershave on, looked at myself in the mirror, and I was like, holy [BLEEP]. It was just, wow, wow, wow. I can't believe this. I can't believe this. Holy [BLEEP]. What the [BLEEP], everything.
当我把它全都刮掉后，我看着自己，抹上须后水，在镜子里看着自己，我当时心想，天哪。就是，哇，哇，哇。我不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。天哪。搞什么鬼，什么都在这儿。
All the holy whatevers, everything was there, everything, all at once. And it was a good feeling, because being broke, unemployed for a whole year-- hypothetically, I saw dollar signs all in the mirror, all around my face, all around everywhere.
所有该死的东西，所有的一切，一下子全都在那儿。那是一种很好的感觉，因为作为一个身无分文、失业整整一年的人——假设一下，我在镜子里看到了美元符号，环绕在我的脸周围，到处都是。
I put on a suit. I didn't even have a suit. I put a suit top. I had a jacket, some bull [BLEEP] shirt, a rinky-dink tie. And I went right back out with the shorts that I had left the bar with.
我穿上一套西装。我甚至没有西装。我穿了一件西装上衣。我有一件夹克，一件烂衬衫，一条破领带。我就穿着离开酒吧时穿的短裤又回去了。
So I leave the house with a suit top and shorts and sandals on the bottom, walk back into the bar, and say, "Hey, guys, what do you think?" And everybody's jaw dropped, like, everybody screaming, like, yo, dude, are you serious? You look just like this dude.
所以我穿着西装上衣、短裤和凉鞋离开家，走回酒吧，说：“嘿，伙计们，你们觉得怎么样？”所有人的下巴都惊掉了，就像，所有人都在尖叫，就像，哟，伙计，你是认真的吗？你看起来就像那个家伙。
I said to Louis, I said, "I'm going to tell you something right now." I said, "There's like, maybe three people in the country that look like him, and he's one of them, in this whole country." You really, really got to look at it long and hard to figure out who is who. It's just striking. If you just, like, gave it a quick glance, dead ringer, like twin brother.
我对 Louis 说，我说：“我现在要告诉你一件事。”我说：“全国大概只有三个人长得像他，而他是其中之一，在这个国家里。”你真的必须盯着看很久才能分清楚谁是谁。这简直太惊人了。如果你只是匆匆瞥一眼，简直是一模一样，就像双胞胎兄弟。
Twin brother is actually a good way of explaining just how much Louis Ortiz really does look like Barack Obama. I've been filming Louis for months, working on a movie about him. And I've looked at his face for hours on end. I've studied the details.
双胞胎兄弟其实是解释 Louis Ortiz 看起来有多像巴拉克·奥巴马的一个好方法。我拍摄 Louis 已经好几个月了，正在制作一部关于他的电影。我盯着他的脸看了无数个小时。我研究了细节。
From certain angles, the resemblance is hard to believe. His right side, slightly from above at 45 degrees, perfect. His left side, slightly from below, is just as good. From those directions, you'd have to take your time to tell him and Obama apart. Also from behind, you know, the ears.
从某些角度看，这种相似度简直让人难以置信。他的右侧，略高于 45 度角，完美。他的左侧，略低于 45 度角，同样出色。从这些方向看，你得花点时间才能分清他和奥巴马。还有从后面看，你知道，耳朵。
There's even details that seem impossible. The hairlines are the same. Louis, just like Obama, has a mole next to his nose. On Louis, it's just on the opposite side. If he smiles, Louis gets that crinkly-eyed thing that Obama gets. And when he gets serious, he does that chin-up, squinty thing too.
甚至有些细节看起来都不可能一样。发际线是一样的。Louis 和奥巴马一样，鼻子旁边有一颗痣。在 Louis 脸上，它只是在相反的一侧。如果他微笑，Louis 也会有奥巴马那种眼角皱纹。当他严肃起来时，他也会做那个下巴上扬、眯眼的动作。
But it's not perfect. The resemblance is at the level of maybe a double take. I've seen people wonder aloud, "Is that him?" And reach for their cameras before they realize it's not. Up close, in person, one second, he's Obama. The next, he's obviously Louis. Then he's Obama. Then he's Louis. It's weird. But back to 2008, back to the Bronx, back to the bar, back to Pat.
但并不完美。这种相似度大概能达到让人回头再看一眼的程度。我见过人们大声怀疑：“那是他吗？”然后伸手去拿相机，还没等意识到那不是本人。近距离接触时，一秒钟，他是奥巴马。下一秒，他显然是 Louis。然后他又变成了奥巴马。然后又是 Louis。这很怪。但回到 2008 年，回到布朗克斯，回到酒吧，回到 Pat 那儿。
And he said, "I'm telling you, Lou, you got something here?" And I'm like, "Yeah, I could see, but what do I got and how do I-- you know, I'm not an actor. How do I do this? Whose door am I knocking on?"
他说：“我告诉你，Lou，你现在有搞头了。”我说：“是啊，我能看出来，但我能做什么，我该怎么——你知道，我不是演员。我该怎么做？我该敲谁的门？”
And he just told me, first things first, you need head shots. So I was like, "What's a head shot?"
他只是告诉我，首先要做的，你需要头像照。我当时说：“什么是头像照？”
Pat Tebelis, the bartender, had what he described to Louis as a little experience in the business, meaning show business. He'd been an extra, done some modeling, a commercial or two. Pat immediately set about mapping a plan for Louis, a plan that, to Louis, sounded far-fetched.
酒吧招待 Pat Tebelis 对 Louis 说他在这行有一点经验，意思是演艺圈。他曾当过临时演员，做过模特，拍过一两则商业广告。Pat 立即着手为 Louis 制定计划，这个计划在 Louis 听起来很遥远。
Keep in mind, this was a rough time in Louis's life. Again, he'd been fired from a job he'd had for more than a decade. He was in the middle of a lawsuit, trying to get his job back. His daughter had just returned home after a nasty custody battle with the parents of his late wife, Louis's late wife, who died of diabetes several years before.
请记住，这是 Louis 生活中的艰难时期。再说一次，他在工作了十多年后被解雇了。他正处于一场诉讼的中间，试图拿回他的工作。他的女儿在他已故妻子的父母（Louis 已故的妻子，几年前死于糖尿病）之间经历了一场恶心的监护权之争后刚回家。
So there he is, sitting across the bar from this guy he barely knows, who's basically telling him he'd hit the jackpot, that his life could be totally different if he just put in a little money up front.
所以他坐在酒吧对面，看着这个他几乎不认识的家伙，这家伙基本上在告诉他他中了头奖，如果他愿意预先投入一点钱，他的生活可能会彻底改变。
He was telling me numbers, like $200 for head shots, $200 for a suit. And you've got to go here and there. And I have my regular, normal, everyday life problems, and I was very reluctant to take the few bucks that I had to go and throw a Hail Mary up. At least I thought it was a Hail Mary.
他跟我说了一些数字，比如 200 美元买头像照，200 美元买西装。你得去这儿去那儿。我有我自己的那种普通的、日常的生活问题，对于要把我仅有的那点钱拿去博一把，我感到非常不情愿。至少我觉得那是博一把。
Louis had his doubts, but he scraped together money for a photo shoot and borrowed money to buy a suit, a new one, and one with pants. He got a list of agents, enlisted some friends. And from the back of the bar, they stuffed envelope after envelope with resumes and head shots.
Louis 有所怀疑，但他还是凑钱拍了照片，借钱买了一套西装，一套新的，而且带裤子的那种。他拿到了一份经纪人名单，拉上了一些朋友。在酒吧后面，他们装信封，一个接一个地装进简历和头像照。
At home, Louis was experimenting with what he started calling the look, practicing in the mirror, then more trips to the bar. It wasn't until sometime in late September that he decided to take it public in a big way, to take it for a real test run.
在家时，Louis 正在尝试他开始称之为“那个外貌”的东西，在镜子前练习，然后又去了几次酒吧。直到 9 月下旬的某个时候，他才决定以一种盛大的方式公之于众，进行一次真正的试运行。
Yeah, I had gotten an invite to a Yankee game. And they were like, "We got an extra bleacher seat." I'm like, "All right, great."
是的，我收到了去洋基队比赛的邀请。他们说：“我们有一张多余的外野看台票。”我说：“好吧，太棒了。”
This was a historic day for the Bronx. It was the last game to be played in the old Yankee stadium, and the park was sold out, filled to capacity.
这对布朗克斯来说是历史性的一天。这是老洋基体育场举行的最后一场比赛，球场票已售罄，座无虚席。
I went into the stadium and went into the bleachers with the suit on. I told the guys I was with-- a bunch of retired cops, couple of telephone guys-- I'm like, "Yo, dude, this is a real crazy look. You guys are really going to protect me, right?"
我穿着西装走进体育场，走进外野看台。我对我那群伙计说——一群退休警察，几个电话公司的人——我说：“哟，伙计，这外貌真是太疯狂了。你们真的会保护我吧？”
And they're like, "Oh, we got you, we got you." I'm like, "OK." Once we get up there, we're all fun and games. They start playing around, like, "Hey, watch it, we got Obama coming through. We got Obama coming through."
他们说：“噢，我们罩着你，罩着你。”我说：“好的。”一旦我们上去，我们都在闹着玩。他们开始瞎闹，说：“嘿，小心点，奥巴马过来了。奥巴马过来了。”
And then, once people from further away started noticing the commotion that was happening, more people started looking. The more people that start looking, the more people that start looking. So everybody's looking, from close to far to-- you know, before you know it-- [SNAPS FINGERS] jumbotron. Everyone said, "Hey, you're on the jumbotron."
然后，一旦远处的观众开始注意到发生的骚动，更多的人开始看着。看的人越多，看的人就越多。所以每个人都在看，从近到远——你知道，还没等你意识到——[打响指] 大屏幕。每个人都说：“嘿，你上大屏幕了。”
And I'm like, "Are you serious?" So I'm like, "Let me go with it." I started waving at people, and people started going nuts. And this is September, a month and a half, or whatever, before election time. Obama had a lot of hype. And it was just exciting.
我说：“你是认真的吗？”我心想：“干脆顺其自然吧。”我开始向人们挥手，人们开始疯狂起来。这是 9 月份，距离选举还有大约一个半月。奥巴马当时声势浩大。这真的很令人兴奋。
Is the game actually happening at this point. Is there baseball happening?
那场比赛当时还在进行吗？棒球比赛还在进行吗？
Baseball is happening, but a lot of fans are lining up to come take pictures with me. People were lining up. Can I get a picture? People were bringing me their babies to kiss their babies and take pictures with their babies.
棒球比赛在进行，但很多球迷排队过来跟我合影。人们在排队。我能拍张照吗？人们把孩子带过来让我亲吻他们的孩子，并跟他们的孩子拍照。
I mean, it was just crazy. It was like, oh my god. You feel like a star. In some weird way, you feel like the president.
我的意思是，这简直太疯狂了。就像，天哪。你感觉自己像个明星。在某种奇怪的方式下，你感觉自己就像总统。
I'm like, damn, how must he feel if I'm feeling like this? And I'm not even the real dude. Imagine how he feels whenever he goes and people are just going crazy over him.
我心想，该死，如果我感觉像这样，那他本人会是什么感觉？而我甚至还不是本人。想象一下，无论他走到哪里，人们都为他疯狂，他会有什么感觉。
On Election Night, Louis, who three months earlier hadn't even heard of Obama, was in the Bronx watching the votes come in like a man with a lottery ticket, watching the winning numbers on TV. At some point, the race hadn't been called, but he put on his suit and headed out of the Bronx.
选举之夜，三个月前甚至还没听说过奥巴马的 Louis 正在布朗克斯看着选票统计，就像一个拿着彩票的人，在电视上看着获奖号码。在某个时刻，虽然比赛还没宣布结果，但他穿上西装，走出了布朗克斯。
We start driving towards Manhattan to hook up with some friends, me and this kid, Benny. And we're like, yo, I want to be downtown when this whole thing goes down. My mother's like, "[UNINTELLIGIBLE] please be safe, please be safe."
我们开始开车前往曼哈顿去见一些朋友，我和这个孩子，Benny。我们说，哟，我想在市中心待着，看整件事是怎么发生的。我妈说：“[听不清] 请注意安全，请注意安全。”
So I start heading down, and all of a sudden, I pull up at a gas station, and I hear gunshots. Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. And I'm like, oh my god, let's get back in the car.
所以我开始朝市中心走，突然间，我停在一个加油站，听到枪声。啪，啪，啪，啪，啪，啪。我说，我的天，快回车里。
And then I hear people screaming. Ah! And I'm like, nobody got shot. People are celebrating. So I turn on the radio, and I just hear people screaming, gunshots, people screaming out the window everywhere. I was in the South Bronx, mind you. So that's when I knew he won. And I'm like, I'm in. I am so in.
然后我听到人们在尖叫。啊！我说，没人被枪击。人们在庆祝。所以我打开收音机，到处都能听到人们的尖叫声、枪声，到处窗外人们都在尖叫。请记住，我在南布朗克斯。所以我知道他赢了。我说，我也在其中。我真的在其中。
I didn't know where I was going to end up. I didn't know if I was going to make a ton of money or a little bit of money, but everybody's celebrating Obama. It's like, everybody's celebrating Obama. So everywhere I walked in with a suit, it was my party. It was my party everywhere I went. And it's a pretty crazy feeling.
我不知道我会去哪里。我不知道我会赚一大笔钱还是一点点钱，但每个人都在庆祝奥巴马。就像，每个人都在庆祝奥巴马。所以无论我穿着西装走进哪里，那都是我的派对。我去的每一个地方都是我的派对。这是一种相当疯狂的感觉。
This could really just turn somebody's life upside down. It turned my life right side up. My life was already upside down.
这真的能把一个人的生活颠倒过来。它把我的生活扶正了。我的生活本来就已经颠倒了。
[CHEERS]
[欢呼声]
This is sound from Washington Square Park, Louis's last stop on Election Night. He got there around 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning, and the crowd was still celebrating. Ever since his big day at the Yankees game, Louis had adopted a sort of homespun guerrilla marketing strategy.
这是华盛顿广场公园的声音，Louis 选举之夜的最后一站。他大概在凌晨 2 点或 3 点到达那里，人群仍在庆祝。自从他在洋基队比赛那天大放异彩后，Louis 就采取了一种类似居家游击队的营销策略。
Mostly, it consisted of, put on a suit, find a place with a lot of people, and just show up. These appearances were for free. Louis got nothing, but he was hoping eventually they'd turn into money.
主要内容就是：穿上西装，找一个有很多人的地方，然后直接出现。这些露面都是免费的。Louis 什么也没得到，但他希望最终能变成钱。
In just a few minutes of tape from Election Night, one after another, people stop Louis. They giggle and point. They use words like "awesome" and "amazing." And they're left with this weird contact high, like they almost met Obama. And they want a picture so they can fool their friends.
在选举之夜短短几分钟的录音中，人们一个接一个地拦住 Louis。他们咯咯笑着指指点点。他们用“太棒了”和“神奇”这样的词。他们陷入了一种奇怪的接触式兴奋，就像他们几乎见到了奥巴马一样。他们想要一张照片，这样就可以戏弄他们的朋友了。
One astonished lady asked him, "What's your name, Obama?" At one point, the crowd mobbed Louis and actually picked him up, carrying him through the air, chanting, Barack Obama, Barack Obama.
一位惊讶的女士问他：“你叫什么名字，奥巴马？”在某个时刻，人群围住了 Louis，竟然把他抬了起来，在空中传递，高喊着，巴拉克·奥巴马，巴拉克·奥巴马。
[CHEERS]
[欢呼声]
Barack Obama was now President Obama, and Louis started getting serious. He signed on with an agent, then two. And to get gigs, one of his agents asked Louis to make a pitch tape, something to send out to people who might hire him.
巴拉克·奥巴马现在是奥巴马总统了，Louis 开始认真起来。他签了一位经纪人，后来又签了一位。为了得到工作，他的一位经纪人让 Louis 制作了一盘推介录像带，用来寄给可能雇佣他的人。
My name is Louis Ortiz. I am a 38-year-old Puerto Rican American who landed the look of a lifetime.
我叫 Louis Ortiz。我是一名 38 岁的波多黎各裔美国人，我获得了终生难得的外貌。
For the tape, Louis wrote the script himself, and filmed it in a stairwell. It's cheap and lo-fi. Louis has his suit on, and he's trying hard, but it's awkward. He's not sure what he's supposed to be doing. At one moment, he turns from side to side in the empty stairwell, waving at imaginary crowds. And then he makes his best attempt at an Obama impression.
对于录像带，Louis 自己写了剧本，并在楼梯间拍摄。这很便宜，而且质量不高。Louis 穿着西装，他很努力，但显得很尴尬。他不知道自己该做什么。有那么一刻，他在空旷的楼梯间里转来转去，向虚构的人群挥手。然后他尽力模仿了一段奥巴马。
Thank you. At this defining moment, change has come to America. With that said, change has also come to my life in a monumental way.
谢谢。在这个决定性的时刻，改变已经来到美国。话虽如此，改变也以一种纪念碑式的方式来到了我的生活中。
And this brings us to Louis's biggest problem. He can't seem to manage a convincing Obama oppression for more than a "thank you" or two. Louis looks more like Obama than any impersonator I've ever seen, but there's a key difference between a look-alike and an impersonator. And that difference is huge in terms of money, the potential money Louis could make doing this.
这把我们带到了 Louis 面临的最大问题。他似乎无法在超过一两句“谢谢”的情况下做出令人信服的奥巴马式压迫感。Louis 比我见过的任何模仿者看起来都更像奥巴马，但长得像的人（Look-alike）和模仿者（Impersonator）之间有一个关键区别。而这个区别在金钱方面——Louis 从中可能赚到的潜在金钱——非常巨大。
I mean, maybe you've seen Reggie Brown or Fred Armisen, guys who do President Obama on late-night TV a lot. They look way less like Obama than Louis, but the impression carries it. But Louis's agent sent out his pitch tape anyway. And pretty soon, he got a call. He landed an audition for HBO for Flight of the Conchords .
我的意思是，也许你见过 Reggie Brown 或 Fred Armisen，这些在深夜电视节目中经常扮演奥巴马总统的人。他们看起来比 Louis 更不像奥巴马，但这种模仿非常到位。但 Louis 的经纪人还是寄出了他的推介录像带。很快，他就接到了一个电话。他获得了为 HBO 拍摄《弦乐航班》试镜的机会。
Yeah, Flight of the Conchords. I'm like, what the hell is that? I never of Flight of the Conchords.
是的，《弦乐航班》。我心想，那是什么鬼？我从没听说过《弦乐航班》。
Flight of the Conchords was a hipster comedy about a band from New Zealand, not really something Louis would watch. But soon, he was in his suit, waiting for the producers to call him in.
《弦乐航班》是一部关于一支来自新西兰的乐队的潮人喜剧，并不是 Louis 会看的那种东西。但很快，他就穿着西装，等待制片人叫他进去。
I'm sitting there at the audition place. They were like, "Oh, yeah, just wait right here." I'm sitting there, and I see this other dude walk in in a suit. He was a light-skinned black dude. And matter of fact, when that dude walked in, I'm like, please don't let some other dude walk in here looking more like Obama than I do.
我坐在试镜地点。他们说：“哦，是的，就等在那儿。”我坐在那儿，看到另一个穿着西装的家伙走进来。他是个肤色较浅的黑人。事实上，当那个家伙走进来时，我心想，请千万别让什么其他家伙走进来，看起来比我更像奥巴马。
I looked at him, he looked at me, and he walked right out. He walked right out.
我看着他，他看着我，然后他径直走了出去。他直接走了出去。
Please put your hands together, the 44th president of the United States.
请大家鼓掌欢迎，美利坚合众国第 44 任总统。
The Flight of the Conchords role was actually perfect for Louis, because they weren't looking for someone to play Obama. They were looking for someone to play an Obama impersonator. In the show-- season two, episode seven, if you're curious-- Louis doesn't appear until the final scene. Here, the joke is that the prime minister of New Zealand thinks he's meeting Obama, but everyone else knows it's not really the president. It's Louis, who in a way is sort of playing himself.
《弦乐航班》的角色对 Louis 来说其实很完美，因为他们寻找的不是扮演奥巴马的人。他们寻找的是扮演奥巴马模仿者的人。在节目中——如果你好奇的话，第二季第七集——Louis 直到最后一幕才出现。在这里，笑点是新西兰总理以为他见到了奥巴马，但其他人都知道那不是真的总统。那是 Louis，在某种程度上，他是在扮演他自己。
Oh yeah, I met him back at the agency. I also do Usher and sometimes Will Smith.
哦是的，我是在经纪公司认识他的。我也模仿 Usher，有时也模仿 Will Smith。
The agency? What's he talking about, mate?
经纪公司？他在说什么，伙计？
Uh, CIA.
呃，中情局（CIA）。
I mean, your first job to be HBO? At that point, I said, wow. I mean, I felt accomplished right there. I felt like I did something, like I really finally did something.
我的意思是，你第一份工作竟然是 HBO？在那一刻，我说，哇。我的意思是，我在那一刻感到很有成就感。我感觉我做了一些事情，就像我真的终于做成了一些事情。
I want to put my daughter to college, and I want to pay all the bills at home, want to get my girl out of debt. I want to buy a house for my mom, all that. Yeah, you think about all that. You think about all of it, and living life, not just surviving, like I have been so many years.
我想送我女儿上大学，我想在家支付所有的账单，想让我女朋友摆脱债务。我想给我妈妈买套房子，所有这些。是的，你会考虑所有这些。你会考虑这一切，并过上生活，而不是像我这多年来那样仅仅是生存。
So it felt within reach.
所以这感觉触手可及。
I thought that this could lead to something really big or something, but not the way it actually did.
我以为这可能会导致一些非常大的事情，但不是像它实际发生的那样。
Day by day, Louis started picking up more work doing Obama. Gradually, it started to feel less like a string of uncertain events, and more like one thing was leading to another. Louis even started calling himself the Puerto-ack Barack. Before he knew it, he was booking high-profile jobs overseas.
一天天过去，Louis 开始接到更多扮演奥巴马的工作。渐渐地，它开始感觉不再是一连串不确定的事件，而更像是一件事接着一件事。Louis 甚至开始称自己为“波多黎各版巴拉克”（Puerto-ack Barack）。在他意识到之前，他已经在海外预订了高调的工作。
There was a big-budget movie in Japan, a comedy where Louis, as Obama, negotiates a fictional peace treaty.
日本有一部大预算的电影，是一部喜剧，Louis 在其中饰演奥巴马，谈判一项虚构的和平条约。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
There was Australia, where Louis was cast as the lead singer of a band, a super-group of Nobel Peace Prize impersonators called the Nobel Funk Off-- Louis as Obama, and various other impersonators as band mates, including Go-Go Gandhi, Nelson the Mandela, Martin Luther the King.
还有澳大利亚，Louis 在那里被选为一支乐队的主唱，这是一支由诺贝尔和平奖模仿者组成的超级乐队，名叫“诺贝尔放克离场”（Nobel Funk Off）——Louis 扮演奥巴马，其他模仿者扮演乐队成员，包括甘地、曼德拉、马丁·路德·金。
This group performed, at one point, for the real actual Dalai Lama. You heard that correctly-- Louis met the Dalai Lama. But Louis's first taste of international work was in Korea, where a company flew him all the way to Seoul to shoot a commercial for a cable service called SkyLife.
这支乐队有一次还为真正的达赖喇嘛表演。你没听错——Louis 见到了达赖喇嘛。但 Louis 第一次尝试国际工作是在韩国，一家公司把他一直飞到首尔，为一家叫 SkyLife 的有线服务公司拍摄广告。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语对话]
Do you know HD has [INAUDIBLE]?
你知道高清有 [听不清] 吗？
The commercial was set to look just like the Inauguration-- podium, teleprompters, Louis in a dark winter coat, and a bunch of non-Asians who'd been rounded up to sit in rows behind him.
那则广告的背景看起来就像就职典礼——讲台、提词器、穿着深色冬大衣的 Louis，还有一堆被召集来坐在他身后排的非亚裔人。
Change, right now.
改变，就在此刻。
[CHEERS]
[欢呼声]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
SkyLife.
SkyLife。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语对话]
And that was how, in a 19-hour plane ride, Louis went from being someone with a bunch of problems he needed help with, to being someone who had people catering to his every need. For example, Louis has MS. Most of the time it doesn't bother him, but he gets tired easy.
这就是 Louis 如何在 19 小时的飞行后，从一个有一堆问题需要帮助的人，变成了一个有人满足他所有需求的人。例如，Louis 患有 MS（多发性硬化症）。大多数时候它不会困扰他，但他很容易感到疲劳。
In Korea, with the jet lag, the busy schedule, he was drained and exhausted and didn't know what to do about it.
在韩国，由于时差和繁忙的日程，他筋疲力尽，不知道该怎么办。
I actually found out that it was on them, that it was OK for me to go get one of those massages from the hotel, the yatsu-- what do you call them?-- massages that the start smacking up your back. Taka, taka, taka, taka, taka. What is that?
我实际上发现这是在他们的费用里，我可以在酒店做那种按摩，雅图——你们叫什么来着？——那种在你背上拍打的按摩。塔卡，塔卡，塔卡，塔卡，塔卡。那是什么？
Shiatsu?
指压按摩（Shiatsu）？
Shiatsu, there you go, one of them massages. Man, once I found that out, I was down there. I hit it at least twice.
指压按摩，对了，就是那种按摩。伙计，一旦我发现了这一点，我就下去了。我至少去了两次。
But I tell you what, I was so in peace out there. Things were so clean out there. People were so humble. Hospitality was incredible.
但我告诉你，我在那儿真的很平静。那儿的一切都那么干净。人们都那么谦逊。好客之情令人难以置信。
To be treated the way I was treated out there, to not see arguments in the street, to not see garbage and stuff like that, coming from the Bronx where I'm from, it just sucked coming back. Coming back was like, am I really going back to the US?
受到在那儿受到的那种对待，在街上看不到争吵，看不到垃圾之类的东西，来自布朗克斯的我，回来感觉太糟了。回来就像，我真的要回到美国了吗？
After Korea, I wanted to move to South Korea. After Japan, I wanted to be in Japan for the rest of my life. After Australia-- that's the latest one-- I want to move to Australia. It's like I feel like that every time I leave the States.
去完韩国后，我想搬到韩国。去完日本后，我想在日本待上一辈子。去完澳大利亚——这是最新的一个——我想搬到澳大利亚。我每次离开美国时都有那种感觉。
The big jobs did come with big paychecks. The Japanese maybe paid the most, $10,000. By the time all of this was in full swing, Louis was making enough to pay off some bills and debts, and do little things like take his girlfriend out to dinner. But the money also went quick.
大的工作确实带来了大支票。日本人可能付得最多，10,000 美元。当这一切全面展开时，Louis 赚的钱足以偿还一些账单和债务，并做一些小事，比如带他女朋友去吃晚餐。但钱也花得很快。
Louis started investing in his new career. He enrolled in acting class, bought another suit, and got his teeth whitened. He even started flirting with the idea of having surgery to close a small gap between his two front teeth, one of the little giveaways that sometimes ruins the Obama look.
Louis 开始投资他的新职业。他参加了表演班，又买了一套西装，还做了牙齿美白。他甚至开始考虑通过手术来关闭两颗门牙之间的小缝隙，这是有时会毁掉奥巴马外貌的小破绽之一。
But even the big ticket jobs weren't really enough to get Louis out of the financial hole he was in, and they tended to be few and far between. Early on, Pat Tebelis, the bartender, had advised Louis, in order to launch this whole new career, this Obama business, that Louis should take any job. There was no telling what could lead to his big break.
但即使是大额工作也没能真正让 Louis 从财务困境中走出来，而且它们往往屈指可数。早些时候，酒保 Pat Tebelis 建议 Louis，为了开启这个全新的职业生涯，这个奥巴马生意，Louis 应该接任何工作。因为谁也说不准什么工作能带来他重大的突破。
And it was advice Louis took to heart. Most of the jobs were the small ones-- emceeing awards ceremonies, political picnics, union rallies, cameos on television. But there were also things that were even stranger, further off the expected path.
这也是 Louis 铭记在心的建议。大多数工作都是小活——主持颁奖典礼、政治野餐、工会集会、电视上的客串。但也有一些更奇怪的事情，偏离了预期的轨道。
I said, OK, rappers pay me some money. I'm going to be in the video. I'm going to play the president.
我说，好的，说唱歌手给我钱。我会出现在视频里。我会扮演总统。
Here's the full premise of the music video Louis was hired to be in. President Obama's helicopter gets shot down, and he's captured and tortured by Arab terrorists. Then the rappers, Waka Flocka Flame and French Montana, show up in full camo, guns blazing, and rescue him.
这是 Louis 被雇佣参与的音乐视频的完整前提。奥巴马总统的直升机被击落，他被阿拉伯恐怖分子俘虏并折磨。然后说唱歌手 Waka Flocka Flame 和 French Montana 穿着全套迷彩服出现，枪声大作，营救了他。
[MUSIC  - "CHOPPA  CHOPPA DOWN" BY FRENCH MONTANA FT. WAKA FLOCKA FLAME]
[音乐 - French Montana 和 Waka Flocka Flame 的《CHOPPA CHOPPA DOWN》]
Because Louis looks so much like the president, the footage from this shoot is very weird to watch. Take after take, Louis is tied up in a chair. There's fake blood all over his shirt. One guy in Arab clothing is pressing a knife to his throat. Another guy is holding a taser and a blowtorch a few inches from his arm.
因为 Louis 看起来太像总统了，这段拍摄的片段看起来非常奇怪。一遍又一遍，Louis 被绑在椅子上。他的衬衫上满是假血。一个穿阿拉伯服装的人把刀抵在他的喉咙上。另一个人拿着泰瑟枪和喷灯，离他的胳膊只有几英寸。
The whole time this is going on, the director is yelling at Louis. But he's not calling him Louis. He's calling him Barack.
这一切发生的时候，导演一直在对着 Louis 大喊大叫。但他不叫他 Louis。他叫他巴拉克。
And rolling camera.
摄像机开始滚动。
Just look at me, Barack. Get mad, Barack.
看着我，巴拉克。生气，巴拉克。
And struggle, struggle, guys, struggle, struggle, struggle. Look towards me, Barack.
挣扎，挣扎，伙计们，挣扎，挣扎，挣扎。看着我这边，巴拉克。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Damn, he looked like Barack, right there. Let me get that--
该死，他看起来就像巴拉克，就在那儿。让我拍那个——
Is there a type of job that you would turn down because you just wouldn't want to lend the president's image to something?
有没有什么工作你会因为不想把总统的形象借给某事而拒绝？
That's my producer, Ben Calhoun, asking that question.
那是我的制片人 Ben Calhoun 问出的那个问题。
A job that I would turn down?
我会拒绝的工作？
Louis stumbled around for over a minute, a minute and 22 seconds, actually--
Louis 磕磕绊绊地说了超过一分钟，实际上是一分钟 22 秒——
I would definitely turn down a few jobs.
我肯定会拒绝一些工作。
--before finally telling us the one job that crossed the line for him.
——在他最终告诉我们那件让他触碰底线的工作之前。
I've had offers to do pornos, like Barack Oboner , Nailin' Palin. I can't see myself doing all that craziness.
我接到过拍色情片的工作，比如《Barack Oboner》，《Nailin' Palin》。我无法想象自己做那些疯狂的事情。
The jobs Louis felt most conflicted about, though, are not the strange things he was asked to do on camera. It's the live appearances. And he did a lot of them. Actually, a lot of the small jobs were ones in which Louis was paid just a little money to show up in person in a suit for a couple hours, kind of like having a living cardboard cut-out of the president to take pictures with.
不过，Louis 感到最矛盾的工作并不是被要求在镜头前做的那些奇怪的事情。而是现场露面。他做了很多。实际上，很多小工作都是 Louis 只要在西装里出现几个小时就能拿到一点钱，就像有一个总统的真人立牌供人们合影一样。
These were some of the fireman. These were two of the friendly ones.
这些人是消防员。这是其中两个友好的。
So those guys were nice to you.
所以那些家伙对你很好。
Yeah. A couple of guys were nice, but it was just so many that weren't.
是的。有几个人人不错，但有太多人很不友好。
Louis showed me pictures from one of these jobs. The number of a bar named Rathbones had hired him to show up and take some pictures on Saint Patrick's Day. The bar was a big hangout for New York firefighters, and there were lots of them there that day. Louis says he figured they'd done a parade, because many were wearing FDNY shirts.
Louis 给看了一张其中一个工作的照片。一家名为 Rathbones 的酒吧雇他在圣帕特里克节那天出现并拍些照片。那家酒吧是纽约消防员的大本营，那天那里有很多消防员。Louis 说他猜他们刚参加完游行，因为很多人都穿着纽约市消防局（FDNY）的衬衫。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[争吵声]
There he is.
他就在那儿。
Move out of the way.
滚开。
There's video of all this. According to Louis, the crowd was a few beers into their day, and they were pretty much hostile from the start. In the video, as Louis walks in, you can hear guys say something about black Irish. Louis looks uncomfortable, nervous.
有这一切的视频。根据 Louis 的说法，人群在当天已经喝了几杯啤酒，他们从一开始就非常敌对。在视频中，当 Louis 走进来时，你可以听到有人说些关于黑人爱尔兰人的话。Louis 看起来很不舒服，很紧张。
He stands with his back against the wall and attempts a presidential wave and smile. Somebody yells, beat it. And then the crowd starts to boo.
他背靠着墙站着，试图做出总统式的挥手和微笑。有人大喊，走开。然后人群开始嘘他。
[CROWD BOOING]
[人群嘘声]
Here, the video suddenly cuts out. Louis says what followed was an hour of people throwing things at him, shoving him, and shouting.
在这里，视频突然中断了。Louis 说随后发生的是长达一个小时的人们向他扔东西、推搡他、大喊大叫。
You're the worst [BLEEP] president. You [BLEEP] suck. [BLEEP] nigger.
你是最烂的总统。你烂透了。该死的黑鬼（nigger）。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, all kinds of horrible things. It was bad.
是的，各种可怕的事情。那太糟糕了。
At one point, Louis was behind the bar serving beers, where things seemed a little safer, with some distance between him and the crowd.
有一次，Louis 在吧台后面供应啤酒，那里看起来安全一点，他和人群之间保持了一定的距离。
I had somebody-- they got on the bar, and they saw me when I started approaching the bar. And he tried to actually grab my head, like, trying to do some motion like that.
我有个人——他们爬上了吧台，当我开始靠近吧台时看到了我。他竟然试图抓我的头，试图做那样的动作。
By motion like that, Louis means that the guy tried to shove Louis's face into his crotch.
通过那样的动作，Louis 是指那个人试图把 Louis 的脸推向他的胯部。
And I just backed up. And I held myself so much from just knocking that dude out. I didn't want to let the Bronx come out of me and just punch somebody in the face, because I'm doing this thing, like I'm the president. So I have to compose myself.
我只是向后退。我极力控制自己，没把那个家伙打昏。我不想让布朗克斯的那一面展现出来直接打某人的脸，因为我在做这件事，就像我是总统一样。所以我必须保持冷静。
Nobody's going scream the N-word to Obama. Nobody's going to have the balls to do that, but they will have the balls-- oh, look at that dude. He looks like Obama. He looks like that N-word.
没人会对着奥巴马喊那个词。没人会有胆量那样做，但他们有胆量——哦，看那个家伙。他看起来像奥巴马。他看起来像那个黑鬼。
Like, wait a second. I've gotta hear this [BLEEP] for him. I've lived in New York City all my life. I know how crazy people in New York are. I've never had to experience the racism like I face it now. It oozes out of people skins now when they see my face.
就像，等一下。我得为他听这些废话。我这辈子都住在纽约市。我知道纽约的人有多疯狂。我从来没有经历过像我现在这样面对的种族歧视。当人们看到我的脸时，它就从他们的皮肤里渗出来。
At first, Louis had friends from the phone company dress up like Secret Service, with earpieces and sunglasses, just for dramatic effect. But after a few bad episodes, Louis got genuinely scared for his safety. Before going out, he would tell his friends to stick close and be ready to actually protect him.
起初，Louis 让电话公司的朋友装扮成特勤局的样子，戴着耳机和太阳镜，只是为了戏剧效果。但在经历了几次糟糕的事件后，Louis 真正为自己的安全感到害怕。在出门前，他会告诉他的朋友们待在一起，准备好随时保护他。
Who's the most belligerent person you've encountered with the whole Obama thing?
在整个奥巴马的事情中，你遇到过最咄咄逼人的人是谁？
The most. Weren't too many words said, but I remember somebody looking at me, walking out drunk out of a bar. And I'm walking in, and he looks at me and he goes, "Oh, man, you're so lucky I'm drunk." And he just started pointing, like if he had a gun in his hand. He's pointing at me like, "You suck."
最多。没说太多话，但我记得有人看着我，喝醉了从酒吧走出来。我正走进去，他看着我说：“哦，伙计，你真幸运我喝醉了。”他开始指着我，就像他手里有枪一样。他指着我说：“你真烂。”
I didn't get called the N-word. I didn't get cursed out. But just the fact that he was drunk, pointing his hand at me like if he had a gun, that was just unnerving. That really bothered me.
我没被叫那个词。我没被咒骂。但仅仅因为他喝醉了，指着我就像他手里有枪，这让我感到不安。这真的困扰了我。
But even with the hecklers, even when these jobs went badly, even when the jobs were hard to come by, the look was an escape for Louis, this weird superpower that he could use any time he wanted. I've watched Louis in front of a crowd of third graders, in a school near his apartment in the Bronx, where they asked him to give a speech.
但即使有挑衅者，即使这些工作进行得很糟糕，即使工作很难找，这种外貌对 Louis 来说是一种逃避，一种他随时可以使用的奇怪的超能力。我在布朗克斯他公寓附近的一所学校里看着 Louis 在一群三年级学生面前，他们让他发表讲话。
Louis was nervous, but when the kids saw him, they saw the leader of the free world, this historic figure. One girl couldn't stop crying. He originally began impersonating Obama for money, to make a few bucks, and it turned out to be so much more than that.
Louis 很紧张，但当孩子们看到他时，他们看到了自由世界的领导人，这个历史人物。一个女孩忍不住哭了。他最初开始模仿奥巴马是为了钱，为了赚点钱，结果发现这远不止于此。
How do I explain this? When I first discovered this look, if I was home, down and out, and I felt down about anything, I'd throw on the suit, shave up, look at myself in the mirror, and I'd go somewhere, hit downtown Manhattan. And now my attitude went from down here to up here.
我该如何解释这一点？当我第一次发现这个外貌时，如果我在家，郁郁不得志，对任何事情感到沮丧，我就穿上西装，刮干净胡子，照照镜子，然后去某处，去曼哈顿市中心。现在我的态度从这里变到了这里。
And now it's up because people look at you. When they see me in the suit, they look at you and they're like, "Oh, wow, dude, do you know who you look like?" And I feel like a million bucks, like I have no problems in the world. I never want that moment to end.
现在它升起来了，因为人们看着你。当他们看到我穿着西装时，他们看着你，然后说：“哦，哇，伙计，你知道你长得像谁吗？”我感觉好极了，就像我世界上没有任何问题。我从来不想那一刻结束。
And when it's all over and I have to go home and take off the suit, that's when it's like, ugh, back to my problems.
而当这一切结束后，我不得不回家脱掉西装时，那就是感觉，哎，回到我的问题中去了。
Unfortunately for Louis, his problems got worse. Louis' new career was tethered to Obama's, and as the president's first term wore on and his approval rating slid, the look-alike jobs slowly disappeared. Eventually, Louis decided to put the Obama stuff on ice, go down to Florida and be with his daughter.
不幸的是，Louis 的问题变得更糟了。Louis 的新职业与奥巴马的职业挂钩，随着总统第一任期的推移和他的支持率下滑，模仿者的工作慢慢消失了。最终，Louis 决定把奥巴马的事情搁置起来，去佛罗里达和他的女儿在一起。
The plan was, he'd go there and wait for his job situation with the phone company, with Verizon, to sort itself out. He said he was looking forward to being Louis the phone guy again.
计划是他会去那里，等待他与电话公司 Verizon 的工作情况得到解决。他说他很期待再次成为电话维修工 Louis。
I went to see him. My first day there, we went fishing in the fenced-in man-made pond outside his parents' apartment complex. And he explained to me his deal with Verizon. Louis had been fired in late 2007. According to him, a string of events led to a heated argument with his boss. Louis stormed out, closed the door pretty hard, kind of slammed it, and the window broke. Louis was fired.
我去看过他。我在那里的第一天，我们去了他父母公寓大楼外围起来的人造池塘钓鱼。他向我解释了他与 Verizon 的协议。Louis 在 2007 年底被解雇。据他说，一连串的事件导致他与老板发生了激烈的争吵。Louis 冲了出去，关门的声音很大，甚至重重地摔上了，窗户也碎了。Louis 被解雇了。
He filed a wrongful termination lawsuit. And in late 2010, his case went to arbitration. If it went his way, he'd get thousands and thousands in back pay.
他提起了不当解雇诉讼。2010 年底，他的案件进入仲裁阶段。如果结果对他有利，他将获得数千美元的补发工资。
My lawyer broke it down. It's pretty much a hands-down case.
我的律师分析了。这基本上是稳赢的案子。
So what's your financial situation?
那你现在的经济状况如何？
Broke as a joke. I mean, I get Obama gigs here and there, but you know my deal. I'm waiting on these boys to pay me my retro-pay from Verizon.
穷得像个笑话。我的意思是，我偶尔会接到奥巴马的工作，但你知道我的情况。我正在等待这些家伙支付我 Verizon 的补发工资。
His lawyer called in late November. When Louis picked up, she didn't sound excited. Louis asked, "Should I be sitting down?" And she said, "Yeah." At that point he knew the arbitrator had sided with Verizon. Louis was now empty-handed, no job back, no retro-pay, not much of anything.
他的律师在 11 月下旬打了电话。当 Louis 接听时，她听起来并不兴奋。Louis 问：“我需要坐下来听吗？”她说：“是的。”在那个时候，他就知道仲裁员已经站在 Verizon 那边了。Louis 现在两手空空，工作没回来，没有补发工资，什么都没有。
My dad has been down here for, like, four months already, probably more, never mind. Like, five, six. I don't know, but he's really cool.
我爸已经在这儿待了大概四个月了，可能更久，别介意。大概五、六个月。我不知道，但他真的很酷。
This is Louis's daughter, Reina. She's 15, a great basketball player, a serious student, funny, and just a really nice kid. Back when the Obama stuff heated up, and Louis was traveling a lot, he sent Reina here to live with his parents.
这是 Louis 的女儿 Reina。她 15 岁，是一名出色的篮球运动员，一名认真的学生，风趣，而且真的是个非常好的孩子。当奥巴马的事情热起来，Louis 经常出差时，他把 Reina 送到这里和他父母住在一起。
They hadn't seen much of each other since. But now the two of them could be a family again. Every day at 5:30 in the morning, Louis would drive Reina to school. And at night, they'd hang out after she got home from basketball practice.
从那以后他们就没怎么见过面。但现在他们两人又能成为一家人了。每天早上 5:30，Louis 都会开车送 Reina 去学校。晚上，她在篮球训练结束后，他们会待在一起。
Yeah, it's kind of better. He's a fun person to be around. That's why I like when he's down here.
是的，感觉好多了。和他在一起很有趣。这就是为什么我喜欢他在的时候。
Louis spent his days in Florida, while Reina was at school, figuring out a plan to piece his life back together. He'd gone to a phone company in Florida, but they said they weren't hiring. At some point, he got in touch with his agent, who told him how successful other Obama impersonators had been, that there was still money to be made. With campaign season approaching, demand would probably be high.
Louis 在佛罗里达度过了他的日子，Reina 在上学，他正在构思计划把生活重新拼凑起来。他去过佛罗里达的一家电话公司，但他们说他们不招人。在某个时刻，他联系了他的经纪人，经纪人告诉他其他奥巴马模仿者有多成功，仍然有钱可赚。随着竞选季节的临近，需求可能会很高。
But his agent said he'd need what he lacking the first time around, a better impression. Specifically she said, work on the voice.
但他的经纪人说他需要第一次所缺乏的东西，一个更好的模仿效果。具体来说，她说，要练习声音。
And I want to thank all of you.
我想感谢你们所有人。
So Louis started watching Obama speeches on YouTube, listening to them on his iPod over and over, practicing the cadence, the timing, and the delivery.
所以 Louis 开始在 YouTube 上观看奥巴马的演讲，在 iPod 上一遍又一遍地听，练习节奏、时机和表达。
Every single American, gay--
每一个美国人，同性恋——
Gay--
同性恋——
--straight--
——异性恋——
--straight.
——异性恋。
--lesbian, bisexual, transgender, every single American--
——女同性恋、双性恋、跨性别者，每一个美国人——
Every single American deserves to be treated equally in the eyes of the law and in the eyes of our society. It's a pretty simple proposition. Now, I don't have to tell you that, uh, we have a ways to go in that struggle.
每一个美国人都应该在法律和我们社会的眼中得到平等的对待。这是一个相当简单的主张。现在，我不用告诉你们，嗯，我们在那场斗争中还有很长的路要走。
As you can hear, Louis really is getting better. And once again, the Obama stuff is starting to feel like Louis's best and only option. But Louis thinks New York is a better place to take another shot, to start getting Obama work again. And that means leaving Reina.
正如你所听到的，Louis 真的在变得更好。再一次，奥巴马的事情开始感觉像是 Louis 最好也是唯一的选择。但 Louis 认为纽约是再次尝试、重新获得奥巴马工作机会的更好地方。而这意味着离开 Reina。
He told me the news, like, two days ago, or three days ago. And it kind of sucks, because I'm going to miss him.
他大概在两天或三天前告诉了我这个消息。这感觉很糟糕，因为我会想念他。
Did you tell him that?
你告诉他了吗？
No. I would never get that emotional with him. I don't know. But I do feel [INAUDIBLE] for him. I wish he could just stay, but he says he has his work to do or whatever over there, so I guess not.
没有。我永远不会在他面前那样情绪化。我不知道。但我确实感到 [听不清] 为他。我希望他能留下来，但他说他有工作要做或者在那边什么的，所以我想不行。
I guess he can't stay, but whatever. I haven't seen him in, like, four years, and then he comes, and then he just leaves again. But whatever. It doesn't bother me.
我想他不能留下，但随便吧。我已经有四年没见过他了，然后他来了，然后他又走了。但随便吧。这并不困扰我。
You believe in that future. That's why you're working hard. That's why you're putting in long hours. You know that doing big things isn't easy, but you haven't given up. That's the spirit we've got to have right now.
你相信那个未来。这就是你努力工作的原因。这就是你投入长时间工作的原因。你知道做大事并不容易，但你没有放弃。这就是我们现在必须具备的精神。
The way it's turned out, right now both the president and Louis are both looking for second chances, both looking back at the last three years, thinking about what they've accomplished and what they still need to do. Recently, Louis was laying out to me his big plans for 2012. Whatever reservations Louis has about leaving Rayna again, that's exactly what he's doing.
事实证明，现在总统和 Louis 都在寻求第二次机会，都在回首过去的三年，思考他们完成了什么以及他们还需要做什么。最近，Louis 向我列出了他在 2012 年的大计划。无论 Louis 对再次离开 Reina 有什么保留意见，这正是他正在做的。
He's doubling down on the whole Obama thing. And he's back in New York. He said he's hopeful. He's feeling good.
他正在全力投入到奥巴马的事情中。他又回到了纽约。他说他很抱歉。他感觉很好。
At some point, I ask Louis, if he could somehow choose, choose between being a great, successful Obama impersonator, or going back to being Louis the phone guy, if he could choose, which one would he pick? He hesitated, seemed to give it some real thought, and he told me, if he could be anyone, if it was totally up to him, he'd go back to his old life, working for Verizon, and be the phone guy, and be himself.
在某个时刻，我问 Louis，如果他能选择，在成为一名伟大、成功的奥巴马模仿者，还是回到电话维修工 Louis 之间做出选择，如果他能选择，他会选哪一个？他犹豫了一下，似乎认真考虑了一下，然后告诉我，如果他能成为任何人，如果这完全由他决定，他会回到他的旧生活，为 Verizon 工作，成为电话维修工，做回他自己。
Ryan Murdock. He is still filming for his movie about Louis. It is called The Audacity of Louis Ortiz. He's looking for more funders on Kickstarter. His website, where you can see just how much Louis looks like Obama, audacitythemovie.com.
Ryan Murdock。他仍在为关于 Louis 的电影进行拍摄。它叫《Louis Ortiz 的胆量》。他正在 Kickstarter 上寻找更多的资金支持。他的网站，在那里你可以看到 Louis 看起来有多像奥巴马，audacitythemovie.com。
Coming up, feigning interest in what your spouse is saying, and how that can save your marriage. That is in a minute, from Chicago Public radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，假装对你的配偶所说的话感兴趣，以及这如何拯救你的婚姻。那将在稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Play the Part, people faking who they are, pretending they are the opposite of their real personalities because they feel they have no other option.
这是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并带给你关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“扮演角色”，人们伪装自己是谁，假装他们与真实的个性相反，因为他们觉得别无选择。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Wife Lessons. Kristen was a speech therapist at a school where she worked with some kids who had autism. Some had Asperger Syndrome.
我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“妻子课程”。Kristen 是一名言语治疗师，在学校里和一些患有自闭症的孩子一起工作。有些人患有阿斯伯格综合症。
It was kind of one of those things. We joked about it, the staff that I worked with, where we kept saying, oh, my husband, or my significant other has Asperger's too. It kind of became this running joke, because there is so many similarities between the neurotypical man, and then you take it a few steps forward and you have Asperger's.
这有点像是那种事情。我们拿它开玩笑，我和我一起工作的员工，我们不停地说，哦，我的丈夫或我的另一半也有阿斯伯格。这有点成为一个持续的笑话，因为神经正常的男人和阿斯伯格之间有太多相似之处，如果你再深入几步，你就会有阿斯伯格。
Not to trivialize how serious Asperger's can be, but the symptoms include emotional distance, inflexibility, missing social cues. A couples counselor once told me that every woman who hears about Asperger's for the first time thinks her husband has it.
不是为了淡化阿斯伯格有多严重，但症状包括情感距离、缺乏灵活性、错过社交暗示。一位夫妻咨询师曾经告诉我，每个第一次听说阿斯伯格的女人都认为她的丈夫患有这种病。
So anyway, they had this joke at work about their husbands all having Asperger's. And then one day it occurred to Kristen-- wait a second, maybe in her case it was not a joke. After all, at the time things were going pretty badly with her husband, Dave. They'd been best friends in high school, started dating in college.
所以无论如何，他们在工作中拿丈夫们都有阿斯伯格开玩笑。然后有一天，Kristen 突然想到——等一下，也许在她的情况下，这不是个笑话。毕竟，当时她和丈夫 Dave 的关系变得很糟糕。他们在高中时是最好的朋友，在大学开始约会。
But once they were married and had two kids, they were in conflict a lot. Any little change in plans would set Dave off, like they would plan to leave a party at 9 o'clock, and Kristen wasn't ready to go until 9:15, and it didn't seem like a big deal to her. Dave would throw what he would call a man-tantrum, and stew about it, obsess about it, not speak to her for days, or a week.
但一旦他们结婚并有了两个孩子，他们就经常发生冲突。任何计划的小小改变都会让 Dave 发火，比如他们计划在 9 点离开聚会，Kristen 在 9:15 之前还没有准备好离开，这对她来说似乎不是什么大事。Dave 会发作他所谓的“男人脾气”，然后对此闷闷不乐，对此着迷，好几天甚至一个星期不跟她说话。
And in these incidents, she was frustrated with him, he felt misunderstood by her. It devastated them both, and it confused them. It stumped them. It really stumped them for years, five years.
而在这些事件中，她对他感到沮丧，他觉得她误解了他。这让他们俩都感到痛苦，而且让他们感到困惑。这让他们困惑。这确实让他们困惑了多年，五年。
And then one day she found this quiz online, this online quiz to help the parents of one of her students. And this quiz was supposed to test different disorders like autism and Asperger's-- 150 questions. Lots of them, like, do you find it necessary to sit in the same seat all the time? Or do you dislike changes in routine? Lots of these questions reminded her of her husband.
然后有一天，她在网上发现了这个测验，这个在线测验是为了帮助她的一名学生家长。这个测验本应测试自闭症和阿斯伯格等不同的障碍——150 个问题。其中很多问题，比如，你是否觉得一直坐在同一个座位上有必要？或者你不喜欢例行公事的改变？这些问题中有很多让她想起了她的丈夫。
He remembers what happened next this way. Things had been pretty chilly between them for a long time. It was around 8 o'clock at night. The kids had been put to bed.
他记得接下来发生的事情是这样的。他们之间的关系很长时间以来一直很冷淡。大概是晚上 8 点。孩子们已经上床睡觉了。
It was so quiet. Kristen had made dinner. And she came up to me, and for the first time in as long as I could remember, out of the blue she approached me and gave me this hug, a real, warm, just tender hug. And I said, "Oh, hello there. How are you doing?" And she just looked up and she said, "When you're ready, why don't you come downstairs to my office. There's something I want to show you."
太安静了。Kristen 做好了晚餐。她走到我面前，这是我记忆中很长一段时间以来，她第一次突然靠近我，给了我一个拥抱，一个真实的、温暖的、温柔的拥抱。我说：“哦，你好。你还好吗？”她抬起头说：“当你准备好时，为什么不来楼下的办公室。有些东西我想让你看。”
So he comes down to the basement, and Kristen starts administering this quiz to him.
所以他来到地下室，Kristen 开始对他进行这个测验。
I remember him saying, at the beginning of it, he's like, "What is this, like, a Cosmo quiz?" I'm like, "No, I'm not taking you down to the basement for a Cosmo quiz."
我记得他在开始时说：“这是什么，就像 Cosmo 测验？”我说：“不，我没把你带到地下室做 Cosmo 测验。”
[LAUGHS] Because that would be hot.
[笑] 因为那会很火辣。
Yeah. We're not going there, buddy.
是的。我们不去那儿，老兄。
Yeah, yeah. So did you tell him, this is going to be a quiz about whether or not you have Asperger's, or you just started asking questions?
是的，是的。所以你告诉他，这是一个关于你是否患有阿斯伯格的测验，还是你只是开始问问题？
No.
不。
No, just started asking questions?
不，只是开始问问题？
No, I just started asking him questions. And as we were going, as the questions got to be so familiar to him, he's like, "What is this quiz? Like, did you write these questions? Did you do this for me?"
不，我只是开始问他问题。当我们进行下去时，随着问题对他来说变得如此熟悉，他说：“这是什么测验？就像，是你写了这些问题吗？你是为我做的吗？”
The ones that really resonated with me were things like, do you find you have most success in social situations when you can script out possible conversations ahead of time? Even things like, do you sometimes feel tortured by the clothes you're wearing, itchy tags, shirt cuffs? Do people often comment on your odd mannerisms and habits? It was a yes, an emphatic yes to all of these things.
真正引起我共鸣的是那些事情，比如，你是否发现你在社交场合最成功的时候是你可以提前写好可能的对话剧本时？甚至像，你有时会因为你穿的衣服感到折磨，瘙痒的标签，衬衫袖口？人们经常评论你奇怪的举止和习惯吗？这对所有这些事情都是肯定的，是一个坚定的肯定。
And then the questions started getting even just bizarre, where I was like, this must be a typo. I remember there was one question about, have you ever fantasized about making traps? And I said, "Oh, that must be a typo." And he's like, "No, I totally have."
然后问题开始变得更加离奇，我想，这一定是个拼写错误。我记得有一个关于的问题，你有没有幻想过设陷阱？我说：“哦，那一定是个拼写错误。”他说：“不，我完全有。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Traps? What are you talking about? So it was when we were starting to get into those specific things, I'm like, jeez, I am just missing this here. This has been in front of me for so long, and I needed this 150-question quiz in order to finally see, oh, OK, that explains a lot.
陷阱？你在说什么？所以当我们开始进入那些具体的事情时，我说，天哪，我在这里完全错过了。这在我面前已经摆了这么久，我需要这个 150 个问题的测验才能最终看到，哦，好的，那解释了很多。
And so you get to the end, and then what do you say? Like, how do you break the news?
所以你到达最后了，然后你说什么？就像，你如何宣布这个消息？
Well, at the very end, you just calculate. And so, when the quiz got done, before I hit calculate, I told him what it was. And he was like, "Oh, OK." So I'm like, "Are you ready to calculate?" So I hit the button, and it was a big, old yes.
嗯，在最后，你只是计算一下。所以，当测验完成后，在我点击计算之前，我告诉了他它是什么。他说：“哦，好的。”所以我说：“你准备好计算了吗？”所以我点了按钮，这是一个大大的、老式的肯定。
It was such a huge moment, a sublime moment. It's a weird way to say it, but I almost felt as though I was present at my own birth, if that's it, if that's a decent way of saying that.
这是一个巨大的时刻，一个崇高的时刻。说出来很奇怪，但我几乎感觉好像我出席了我自己的出生，如果那是，如果这是说出来的体面方式的话。
I mean, it was as if somebody finally handed me a user manual for myself. You know, here's how you operate, and if you read this manual, everything that was difficult in life before is going to be a lot easier now, because it makes sense and you can learn how to control certain things.
我的意思是，这就好像有人最终递给我一本我自己的用户手册。你知道，这就是你的操作方式，如果你读了这本手册，以前生活中所有困难的事情现在都会容易得多，因为这说得通，你可以学习如何控制某些事情。
Kristen found it just as comforting. All the things that seemed to be destroying their marriage, she could see now that they were not his fault. And she hadn't realized just how hard things were for him in everyday situations. So they went to a doctor and they got the diagnosis confirmed. David had Asperger's.
Kristen 发现它同样令人欣慰。所有似乎在摧毁他们婚姻的事情，她现在可以看到那不是他的错。而且她没有意识到他在日常生活中面临着多大的困难。所以他们去看医生，诊断得到了证实。David 患有阿斯伯格。
Typically, people with Asperger's have trouble reading social cues, they have trouble interacting, they're usually obsessive in their routines or interests. And then, armed with this diagnosis, Dave set about fixing whatever it was possible to fix. And he did this with the deep obsessiveness of a deeply obsessive person.
通常，患有阿斯伯格的人在解读社交暗示方面有困难，他们难以互动，他们通常在例行公事或兴趣方面痴迷。然后，凭借这个诊断，Dave 开始修复任何可能修复的东西。而且他带着一个极其痴迷的人的深刻痴迷感做了这件事。
He understood, OK, there's clearly a gap between his instincts and the way that other people acted. And he wanted to close that gap by imitating them. So he started keeping this list. Whenever he stumbled onto some kind of behavior that he wanted to change, any behavior that was causing friction between him and Kristen, he would write it down. For instance--
他明白，好的，他的本能和其他人行动的方式之间显然存在差距。他想通过模仿他们来缩小那个差距。所以他开始保留这份清单。每当他碰到某种他想改变的行为，任何导致他和 Kristen 之间摩擦的行为，他都会把它写下来。例如——
It would really bother her when she would be singing along in the radio and she'd be in a good mood and happy and I would change the station mid-song. And so she would say, "Are you kidding? You can't do that."
当她在收音机里跟着唱，心情很好很高兴，而我中途换台时，那真的会困扰她。所以她会说：“你是认真的吗？你不能那样做。”
So I would write it down. I would say, OK, you know what, I really want to change things. So lest I forget, I'm going to put it somewhere. So I'd write it down on a notepad-- don't change the radio station when she's singing along.
所以我会把它写下来。我会说，好的，你知道吗，我真的很想改变事情。所以为了不忘记，我要把它放在某个地方。所以我把它写在记事本上——当她跟着唱的时候不要换广播电台。
Now, if that just seems unbelievably basic, you can see why he and Kristen had been fighting for five years, and why he needed a list. He started to call all these little scraps of paper that he was doing this on, he started to call it, "The Journal of Best Practices." Other items on the list-- don't sneak up on her, better to fold the laundry and put it away than only take what you need from the dryer, give Kristen time to shower without crowding her.
现在，如果那看起来难以置信的基本，你可以明白为什么他和 Kristen 吵了五年，以及为什么他需要一个清单。他开始称所有这些他做这些的小纸条，他开始称它为“最佳实践日志”。清单上的其他项目——不要偷偷靠近她，最好叠好衣服并把它收起来，而不是只从烘干机里拿你需要的东西，给 Kristen 洗澡的时间而不拥挤她。
Well, some of them were actually quite profound, things like, learn how to listen. I mean, that's a huge one.
嗯，其中一些实际上相当深刻，比如，学习如何倾听。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的。
Wait a minute. How do you operationalize that one?
等一下。你如何将其付诸实施？
Well, learn how to listen-- for example, she would maybe have a complaint about something that happened in her day, you know, somebody at work was so annoying today, or it's taking me so long to get to work, man, with all this traffic. And what I would do is I would offer her a million solutions. Let's sit down, let's map out this traffic route that you're taking. We can optimize travel time versus rush hour versus stoplights.
嗯，学习如何倾听——例如，她可能对发生在一天中的事情有抱怨，你知道，在工作中的某个人今天很烦人，或者带我上班花了我太久的时间，伙计，所有的这些交通。而我会做的是我会提供她一百万个解决方案。让我们坐下来，让我们规划一下你正在采取的交通路线。我们可以优化旅行时间与高峰时间与交通灯。
And she would just stare at me like, are you kidding me? And just say, ultimately, "No I'm good." And just leave. And then I would feel hurt, like where are you going? If you didn't want a solution, why did you bring this up?
而她只会盯着我，就像，你在开玩笑吗？然后最终说，“不，我很好。”然后就离开了。然后我会感到受伤，就像你要去哪儿？如果你不需要解决方案，你为什么要提起这个？
Well, what I didn't know, and what she didn't know, was I just needed to be told sometimes, "Dave, look, I have some things on my mind, I don't need a solution, all I want you to do is, when I'm done talking, just nod your head and say, that must be rough." [LAUGHS] I could literally practice doing that.
嗯，我不知道的，她也不知道的，是我有时只需要被告知，“Dave，看，我心里有些事情，我不需要解决方案，我只想让你做的是，当我谈完时，只是点头并说，那一定很粗糙。” [笑] 我可以真正练习那样做。
Now, sometimes I got it wrong. Like, she would come to me seeking a solution. "This house is absolutely a disaster. I can't clean this up all by myself." And I would say, "Yeah, I totally hear you, that's gotta be so rough." And then I would just leave the room.
现在，有时我搞错了。就像，她会来到我身边寻求解决方案。“这房子简直是一场灾难。我不能一个人清理这个。”我会说，“是的，我完全听到了，那一定很粗糙。”然后我就离开了房间。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Kristen says that, all of his life, Dave had gotten by by imitating the way people around him behave. And he had a real talent for noticing little things that people did and then copying them, and now that really kicked in hard.
Kristen 说，他一生中，Dave 一直通过模仿他周围人们行为的方式来生存。他有真正注意到人们做的小事情然后复制它们的天赋，现在那真的硬生生地发挥了作用。
So he was able to start learning how to, again, in quotes, "look normal, look neurotypical" by doing things like watching The Late Show With David Letterman , listening to Howard Stern.
所以他能够开始学习如何，再次，在引号中，“看起来正常，看起来神经典型”，通过做像看《大卫·莱特曼深夜秀》，听 Howard Stern 这样的事情。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Wait, wait. Your husband learned to talk to other human beings by listening to Howard Stern and watching David Letterman?
等等，等等。你的丈夫是通过听 Howard Stern 和看 David Letterman 来学习与其他人交谈的？
He learned how to have small-talk conversations, the flow of conversations, when they were kind of going to change, what their facial expression might look like, or their body language might look like when they're about to switch topics, or kind of how to just go with the flow during a conversation.
他学习了如何进行小谈话，对话的流程，当它们有点要改变时，当他们要转换话题时，他们的面部表情可能看起来像什么，或者他们的肢体语言可能看起来像什么，或者在对话过程中如何顺其自然。
I had always listened to Howard Stern.
我一直听 Howard Stern。
I love Howard.
我爱 Howard。
Right. So you know, as a Howard listener, it's engaging. Well, what I started keying in on was the way that Howard would get through a story, parse a story. He's talking about going out and getting pancakes with his parents last weekend, and he'll keep that up for 30, 45 minutes if he has to.
对。所以你知道，作为一个 Howard 听众，它是引人入胜的。嗯，我开始锁定的是 Howard 通过一个故事，解析一个故事的方式。他在谈论上周末和父母出去吃煎饼，如果他必须的话，他会把那个维持 30、45 分钟。
He's able to take interruptions from the other people in the studio, from Robin, from Gary, from callers. And when he wants to be sincere, he'll lower his voice, and he'll slow down, maybe much like what I'm doing right now, because that's kind of who I learned from, was Howard.
他能够接受演播室里其他人、Robin、Gary、来电者的插话。当他想真诚时，他会降低声音，他会放慢速度，也许就像我现在正在做的，因为那是我从 Howard 那里学到的。
So I would take notes on how he did this, and then I would practice. Sometimes I got it right. Sometimes I got it way wrong. So if I was--
所以我会在他如何做这个方面做笔记，然后我会练习。有时我做对了。有时我做错了。所以如果我是——
Can you give me an example of a time that it went way wrong?
你能给我一个它完全搞砸的例子吗？
[LAUGHS] I can give you lots of examples of those. I think trying to start some banter with one of the engineers in my lab, somebody that I never talk to about anything besides how our oscilloscopes work. So I would sit down and say things like, "So listen, whatcha doing over there? You got anything going on sexually in your life, anything going on love life that--"
[笑] 我可以给你很多这样的例子。我认为试图在我的实验室里的一名工程师开始一些玩笑，除了我们示波器如何工作之外我从来不谈论任何事情的人。所以我坐下来，说些像，“所以听着，你在那儿做什么？你在生活中性方面有什么事情，或者爱情生活中有什么事情，那个——”
Wait, you actually said this to somebody at work?
等等，你真的对工作中的某人说了这个？
Just to see how they would react. And sometimes people would just start laughing, and sometimes they would actually engage the conversation. And then other times, they would just say, like, "Are you kidding me?"
只是为了看看他们会有什么反应。有时人们会开始笑，有时他们会真正参与对话。然后其他时候，他们只会说，就像，“你在开玩笑吗？”
So David's trying all these things to try to change his behavior. And overall, it works. The first thing that he notices is that there is an absence of resentment between him and Kristen. And things just get better and better.
所以 David 正在尝试所有这些事情来试图改变他的行为。而且总的来说，它有效。他注意到的第一件事是，他和 Kristen 之间没有怨恨。事情变得越来越好。
And then his problem is, he's obsessive by nature-- like, that's his whole diagnosis, right? And he starts wanting regular performance reviews from Kristen. He puts together these PowerPoint slides for these reviews. And a year and a half into this, she has had enough of the "Journal of Best Practices." And she has to tell him, we have learned what we needed to learn from this.
然后他的问题是，他天生痴迷——就像，那是他的整个诊断，对吗？他开始想要 Kristen 的定期绩效评估。他为这些审查制作了 PowerPoint 幻灯片。一年半进入这个，她已经受够了“最佳实践日志”。她不得不告诉他，我们已经学会了我们需要从中学习的东西。
That's the point where we ordered out or something, and he ate all the crab rangoon. And I just kind of was like, "Ugh, you ate all the crab rangoon." And all of a sudden now that's a best practice. So that's kind of where I stopped it.
那是我们订餐或其他什么的时候，他吃了所有的蟹角（crab rangoon）。我有点像，“哎呀，你吃了所有的蟹角。”而突然间现在那是一个最佳实践。所以这就是我停止它的地方。
And I said, you know what, we don't have to work on this for the next three weeks. Just don't eat all the crab rangoon. And so I had to explain to him, people who are married still-- it's OK if I sigh and roll my eyes when you eat all the crab rangoon, like, that's OK.
我对他说，你知道吗，我们不必在接下来的三周内处理这个。只是不要吃所有的蟹角。所以我不得不向他解释，结婚的人仍然——当由于你吃光了所有的蟹角，我叹气并翻白眼是可以的，就像，那是没问题的。
Best practices is done. We have the essentials. The things that were really difficult for us, we got. Leave the crab rangoon out of it.
最佳实践完成了。我们有基本的东西。对我们来说非常困难的事情，我们得到了。把蟹角排除在外。
And that must have been hard for him.
那对他来说一定很难。
It was. That was one of the best practices that I gave him. I was like, here's your new best practice. Not everything is a best practice. And so I'm sure he went and ran and wrote it down in his journal, like, OK, not everything's a best practice.
是的。那是我给他的最佳实践之一。我当时就像，这是你的新最佳实践。并非每件事都是最佳实践。所以我敢肯定他跑去把它写在他的日志里，就像，好的，并非每件事都是最佳实践。
David is still faking his way through things today. He listens to Kristen's problems at the end of the day, and he waits until it's time for him to say, that sounds hard, and then he says, that sounds hard. And it's gotten pretty comfortable.
David 今天仍然在假装通过事情。他在一天结束时听 Kristen 的问题，他等到该他说的时候，那听起来很艰难，然后他说，那听起来很艰难。而且它变得非常舒服。
At some point in this process, it felt like it did become second nature. I can't claim that it's true empathy. It's more intellect than it is just raw--
在这个过程中的某个时候，它感觉确实成为了第二天性。我不能声称这是真正的同理心。它是理智比它仅仅是原始的——
Feeling.
感觉。
--empathy and emotional response. Exactly, it's knowing versus feeling. I've achieved something that very much resembles empathy, and it's close enough for us.
——同理心和情绪反应。确切地说，它是知道与感觉。我已经实现了一些非常类似同理心的东西，而且它对我们来说足够接近。
But wait, is that satisfying for her? I mean, if you say to her, like, god, that must be terrible for you, and you're not really empathizing, and she knows you're just saying it by rote because you've been trained to do it, is that actually satisfying to her?
但等等，这对她来说令人满意吗？我的意思是，如果你对她说，比如，天哪，那对你来说一定很糟糕，而你并没有真正共情，而她知道你只是因为你被训练去做那件事而机械地在说它，这对她来说实际上令人满意吗？
That's a really great point. I can now surmise, using intellect, that, yes, that must've been very trying for her. Whether that's satisfying to her, maybe it would come as no surprise, I hadn't really thought about it too much in those terms.
这是一个非常好的点。我现在可以推测，利用理智，是的，那一定对她来说非常艰辛。这是否让她满意，也许这不足为奇，我还没有真正从这些术语考虑它太多。
Maybe it's not exactly heartfelt, but I don't now. I guess it works well enough for me.
也许它不完全是真诚的，但我现在不知道。我想它对我来说足够好。
And that's kind of the question. If your spouse is pretending to be like everyone else who is in a marriage, is that just as good as them being like everyone else in a marriage?
而那就是那个问题。如果你的配偶假装像婚姻中的每个人一样，那是否和他们像婚姻中的每个人一样好？
No. Well, I don't know. I mean, I think, as the wife, I wanted him to have empathy. I wanted him to put my feelings first, just in general. There are times when I wish he truly understood, I think.
不。嗯，我不知道。我的意思是，我认为，作为妻子，我想要他有同理心。我想要他把我的感受放在第一位，只是在一般情况下。有时候我希望他真正理解，我认为。
But I did understand that that's just not how his brain was wired. Of course you want someone just to be able to magically do that, to read your mind, but that's not going to happen. I mean, that's every marriage.
但我确实明白那不是他的大脑连接的方式。当然你想要某人只是能够神奇地做到那一点，能够读懂你的心，但那不会发生。我的意思是，那是个婚姻。
You know, why won't he just do what I want him to do? Well, because he's not a mind-reader. But so, OK, I'm going to tell him, this is how I need you to react, and it worked.
你知道，为什么他不会只是做我想要他做的事情？嗯，因为他不是读心者。但所以，好的，我要告诉他，这是我需要你反应的方式，而且它奏效了。
And the fact that he's going through the trouble in a way is showing that he cares.
而且他经历麻烦的事实，在某种程度上表明他在意。
Absolutely.
绝对。
I was playing a draft of this story for three of the This American Life producers. And I got done with it, and all four of us kind of admitted to each other that, in our own marriages, either we've been instructed or we have instructed our spouse the exact same thing that Kristen told Dave. Just listen to me complain about my day, or whatever it is, and then here is what I want you to say.
我正在为三位《美国生活》制片人播放这个故事的草稿。我完成了它，我们四个人都有点向对方承认，在我们自己的婚姻中，要么我们被指示，要么我们指示了我们的配偶 Kristen 告诉 Dave 的完全相同的事情。只是听我抱怨我的一天，或者不管它是什么，然后这是我想要你说的。
And in those moments, when you go through the motions for the person that you love, and say what they want you to say because they specifically said that's what they need-- we have all had the experience in our marriages-- that does the job. That works just fine.
而在那些时刻，当你为你爱的人走过那些动作时，说他们想要你说的话，因为他们专门说那是他们需要的——我们在我们的婚姻中都有过那种体验——那完成了工作。那很好用。
David Finch has written a book about all this called The Journal of Best Practices . His wife, Kristen, says that women are constantly asking her for the link to that questionnaire that she gave her husband. So you can find that out our website, thisamericanlife.org.
David Finch 已经写了一本关于这一切的书，叫《最佳实践日志》。他的妻子 Kristen 说，女性不断地向她询问她给丈夫的那个问卷的链接。所以你可以在我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org 上找到它。
[MUSIC -"SWEET INSPIRATON"  BY THE SWEET INSPIRATIONS]
[音乐 - The Sweet Inspirations 的《SWEET INSPIRATON》]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream all of our old shows for absolutely free, subscribe to our podcast. And we have posted right now, a listener's survey. It would help us find more listeners like you if we knew who you are. So I hope you'll consider taking a minute to fill it out. Again, that's thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流式传输我们所有的旧节目，订阅我们的播客。我们现在已经在那里发布了一项听众调查。如果我们知道你是谁，它会帮助我们找到更多像你一样的听众。所以我希望你会考虑花一分钟填写它。再一次，那是 thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who starts his new sexual harassment in the workplace training video this way.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板 Torey Malatia 先生负责，他以这种方式开始了新的职场性骚扰培训视频。
So listen, whatcha doing over there? You got anything going on sexually in your life, anything going on love life?
所以听着，你在那儿做什么？你在生活中性方面有什么事情，或者爱情生活中有什么事情？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是 Ira Glass，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。